[موسيقى]
وللمره السادسه الى رئاسه الوزراء
اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
الدوله
الى اسرائيل من اهم اولوياته حكومه
الداخليه
الى دوله دينيه اصليه
تتشاهموا وعاردوها وكيف سيتعامل معها
جيرانها العرب والمجتمع الدولي اهلا بكم
في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اخيرا تشكلت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده والتي توصف بانها
الاكثر تطرفا سياسيا ودينيا واجتماعيا على
راسها ومن ركائزها لتمار بن كثير
ابرزهولات المستوطنين زعيم حزب العظمه
اليهوديه وفيها بثلائي سومترتش زعيم حزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه وزيرا للماليه ودرعي
زعيم حزب شات وزيرا للداخليه
عن الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده والكيفيه
التي سيواجه بها الفلسطينيون تطرفها وما
تثيره من ردود فعلا داخل اسرائيل ولد
جيرانها العرب والمجتمع الدولي يسعدنا ان
يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستديو
الدكتور احمد جميل عزام استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه قطر من القدس الدكتوره
هنيدي غانم مديره المركز الفلسطيني
للدراسات الاسرائيليه مدار ومن نيويورك
ريتشارد
الامريكي في مفاوضات السلام بالشرق الاوسط
السابقه
حكومه يمنيه متطرفه اذا باتت تتسيد المشهد
في اسرائيل وبعدما رافق الجدل داخليا
وخارجيا من مراحل التفاوض لتشكيلها فهي
الملامح الاولى في اعتداء اعتداءاتها على
المقدسات والانسان الفلسطيني واصدامها مع
الشارع الداخلي وخلافاتها مع المجتمع
الدولي تتجلى الان وبيضوح
[موسيقى]
عاد نتنياهو على راس حكومه تنظر بمرحله
تصعيد قد يكون غير مسبوق في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه لقد كانت عودته لقاء ثمان
معلوم من التنازلات المثيره التي قدمها
لخلفائه في الاحزاب اليمنيه والدينيه
المتشدده
الاقصى هذه المره بصفته صاحب السلطه انه
وزير الامن القومي في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تكشف اتفاقات وتشكيل الائتلاف الحكومي ان
نتنياهو فوضى الى بنك فير تولي ملف الامن
في الداخل الفلسطيني بينما تولى زعيم
تحالف الصهيونيه الدينيه باسرائيل سوترتش
الاداره المدنيه في الضفه الغربيه فبات
بذلك الوضع مرشح لتصعيد غير مسبوق قد يمتد
الى داخل الخط الاخضر ذلك ان سيطره اليمين
المتطرف على صناعه القرار الامني قد تحول
عقيده هذه الاحزاب الى سياسات ضد
الفلسطينيين وياتي تعزيز النشاطات
الاستيطانيه ومنحها غطاء الشرعيه في صداره
اولويات الحكومه الجديده
ليست هذه مخاوف الفلسطينيين وحدهم في
الداخل الاسرائيلي ايضا يعتقد ان توجهات
حكومه نتنياهو ستعمق الشرخ بتحفيظ اصطدام
بين العلمانيين والمتدينين
فوحدها هذه الحكومه حاله قبلت باحتجاجات
في الشارع حتى قبل تشكيلها وماء كشف مضمون
اتفاقات تشكيل هذا الائتلاف حتى تاكدت
مخاوف المعارضه الاسرائيليه
لنهج اسرائيلي طويل الاماد في قطاعات
سياديه مثل الدفاع والامن والتعليم
يعتقد في اوساط المعارضه الاسرائيليه ان
السياسات هذه الحكومه حازو لتعزيز الهويه
القوميه اليهوديه وفقا لتفسيرات التيارات
الدينيه المتشدده انها براي كثيرين مؤشرات
اصدام داخلي اسرائيلي قريب
واذا كان رئيس الحكومه الجديده قد عهد
بملفات الامن الداخلي الى حلفاءه فانه
سيتولى بنفسه الملفات الخارجيه ترجح
تقديرات مركز ابحاث الامن القومي التابعي
لجامعه تل ابيب
على المستوى الاقليمي والدوليه
الاداره الامريكيه التي ما زالت مساعيها
لابرام اتفاق النووي مع ايران مستمره
وباضافه ذلك الى تجديد حلفائه المتوقع
للقبضه السياسيه والامنيه على الفلسطينيين
تكون اسرائيل على الارجاح مقبله على مرحله
التوتر في علاقاتها الخارجيه
سريعا بدات الملامح الاولى لذلك تتشكل
فاقتحام بن كثير للمسجد الاقصى قبل
بتحذيرات امريكيه وفرنسيه وبريطانيه من اي
تغيير للوضع القائم في الاماكن المقدسه ما
يشيء ببدء الابتعاد من سياسات الحكومه
الجديده
بدل نهج المتطرف لهذه الحكومه
ركز الاتفاق داخليا على ان للشعب اليهودي
حقا خالصا غير قابل للجدل على ارض اسرائيل
كما شدد على المحافظه على الطابع اليهودي
للدوله وان الحكومه ستعمل على تعزيز هجره
اليهود الى اسرائيل من كافه دول العالم
كما ستعمل على تطوير الاستيطان في كل
ارجاء اسرائيل في الجليل والنقب والجلال
والضفه الغربيه
وفيما يتعلق بالقدس
على العمل على تعزيز مكانه القدس عاصمه
لاسرائيل
الفلسطيني قال الاعلان ان الحكومه ستحرص
على دعم قوات الامن والجنود في الحرب على
ما سماه بالارهاب كما فوضى الى جهاز الامن
شباب التدخل في مكافحه العنف والجريمه في
المجتمع العربي
ومراقبه شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي تحت
دريعه منع التحريض واثاره الشغب
خارجيا قال الاعلان ان الحكومه ستعمل على
تحقيق السلام مع الجيران مع الحفاظ على
مصالح اسرائيل الامنيه التاريخيه والقوميه
وفي شان الايراني اكد الاعلان ان الحكومه
ستواصل العمل في محاربه المخطط النووي
الايراني بكافه الوسائل المتاحه
دكتور
اهلا وسهلا بك اهلا وسهلا فيك ما اسوا ما
ينتظر الفلسطينيين من مجمل ما ذكرناها
الان ربما لا يوجد حكومه اسرائيليه مثل
هذه الحكومه تحمل رزمه متكامله معده
للفلسطينيين داخل الاراضي المحتله سنه 67
تحديدا وحتى في كامل فلسطين التاريخيه همم
ودعني اقول ربما جزء كبير مما ي- يعني
نراه رغم كل ما نراه فان هذا ربما فقط راس
الجبل الجليد هناك الكثير من الامور تجري
تحت الارض التي حتى ان لم تنفجر في هذه
الحكومه ولكنها تتفاعل حتى تنفجر في
السنوات القادمه يعني على سبيل المثال هذه
الحكومه
بالوزيرينش يقال او هي حكومه الصهيونيه
الدينيه التي تؤمن بان يعني بتؤمن همم
صهيونيه متدينه تختلف كثيرا عن الصهيونيه
العلمانيه تختلف عن الاصوليه الدينيه حتى
يعني فنحن نتحدث عن شيء مختلف ايه يؤمن
بايمان قوم في الدين بشكل كبير ولكن هذا
الكلام ليست الحكومه فقط ما يجري الان وما
سيفعله بنجفير بانه هناك اصلا الجيش
الاسرائيلي نفسه يعني عندما نقول بني كثير
الان
سيتاولى موضوع حرس الحدود وسما تريش
الاداره المدنيه التي هي مسؤوله عن الشؤون
اليوميه في الحياه الاسرائيليه ايضا هم
سيمهد في هذه الحاله لتشكيل مليشيات
مستوطنين همم يقومون بنفسهم
في المستوطنات
وهم ناشطين داخل المستوطنين لكن المليشيات
المستوطنين شبيبه التلال ما يسمى منظمه
شبيبه التلال على سبيل المثال هذه منظمه
للشباب اليهودي المتدين الصهيوني هذه
سيطلق يدها وهذا سيكون امر صعب جدا ما
نراه في منطقه حواره مثلا في جنوب نابلس
همم مثال على ذلك ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي
نفسه هناك وحدات في الجيش الاسرائي ايه
اللي يعني ربما الاعلام لا يغطيها تماما
ولكن في السنوات الاخيره اصبحت امر مهم
جدا يعني مثلا في كتيبه تسمى نتساه يهودا
هذه الكتيبه فقط لليهود المتدينين همم
الاصوليين او يعني الصهيونيه الدينيه لم
تدخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه فقط ولكن دخلت
الجيش الاسرائيلي بكثاء خاصه
يعني الان هناك الاستيطان ربما لاول مره
لاول مره همم تدار الاراضي المحتله من قبل
غلاه المستوطنين ربما يعني ليس فقط يؤمنون
بالفكر الاستيطان وانما هم مستوطنون اصلا
همم الاستيطان هناك الاستيطان هناك موضوع
القدس هناك موضوع همم المزيد من
الاقتحامات للمسجد الاقصى يعني من بين هذه
ما ما اكبر ما اريد ان اصل اليه من هذه
المقدمه حول تركيبه المستوطنين
والميليشيات وتركيبه الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي يتولى شؤون الض غربيه الان ان هذه
هؤلاء جميعهم لديهم عقيده سينفذوها يعني
عقيده الترانسفير الموجوده للترحيل ترحيل
الفلسطينيين الموجوده لدى بيني كثيره الذي
يرفع شعار واضح ان هذه هذا الفلسطيني يجب
ان يخرجهم يجبقوا المستوطنات الان شرعا
الجميع البؤر ما يسمى البؤر الاستيطانيه
غير الشرعيه طبعا نحن نعلم ان كل
المستوطنات غير شرعيه ولكن حتى بالقانون
الاسرائيلي هناك عشرات المستوطنات غير
المشرعه الان سيشارعها همم مستوطنات كبرى
مثلا في موضوع مثلا مطار قلنديا الذي كان
قبل سنه 67 هو مطار القدس الان هناك مخطط
لمشروع ضخم جدا في هذه في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي القدس تقسيم المسجد الاقصى
المكانيه الان
يقول بانه اليهود يدخلون اصلا من بعد صلاه
الفجر وحتى تقريبا قبال الظهر هو يريد ان
يجعل ذلك 24 ساعه وربما تقسيم مكانه
وزمالك كما يحدث في المجلس ايضا طبعا كما
يج المسجد المسجد الابراهيمي في الخليل في
المسجد الابراهيمي الخليل قسم مكانيا
وزمانيه بمعنى ان هناك مكان لليهود ومكان
المسلمين الان يريد ان يفعل نفس الشيء في
المسجد الاقصى وبالتالي نحن تحدث
استيطانيه ترحيل ايضا يريد ان يشارعن بانه
كل من يلقي حجر يمكن قتله يمنع ملاحقه اي
جندي اسرائيلي اا يريد ان يعطي حصانه تامه
للقتل همم الهدم ليس فقط لمن
لبيت من ينفذ عمليه فدائيه او مقاومه ولكن
حتى للعائلات الاخرى عقبات جماعيه من شكل
سحب تصاريح عمل وتحرر 19 تصريح الحركه
لقرى باكملها هذا المخطط هل يحدث ذلك اذا
لم يحدث جميعه فان جزء كبير منه سيحصل
يعني هذا ما ينتظر الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه وغزه ماذا بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
داخل الخط الاخضر دكتور هنيدي غانم اهلا
وسهلا بك
اهلا وسهلا بك انا بعتقد انه في هناك مخطط
للعوده للتعامل مع الفلسطينيين في الداخل
من خلال المنطقه الحكم العسكري الذي كان
سائد سابقا واذا نظرنا الى الاتفاقيات
الخطوط العريضه نجد انه اكثر ما يتكرر
الحديث عنه هو عمليه مجابهه العنف والقضاء
على العنف والمفيات وغيره من الكلمات
المختلفه للهدف منها في نهايه الامر هو
حصر قضايا الفلسطينيين في الداخل وكانها
مرتبطه فقط بقضايا العنف وقضايا الجريمه
وامام هذا طبعا اضافه همم مهم جدا الى
الحديث عن انفاد القانون همم في مناطق
النقاب وايضا السيطره والتهويد بقدر ما
يمكن من اراضي موجوده في منطقه الجليل وفي
منطقه النقب الفارق بين المنطق اللي كان
سائد يمكن في فتره الحكم العسكري خلال حكم
باي انه كان في هناك منظور للتعامل من
خلال ثنا العصا والجزره النظر حاليا لخطوط
العريضه والتصريحات
والممارسه
والوعيد اللي همم
يتوعد في مثلا بين كبير بالنسبه
للفلسطينيه في الداخل ان هناك حديث عن عصا
بدون جزر بمعنى النظر فقط من خلال فوهه
همم خلينا نقول القمع قوه الاخضاء واعتبار
ان الفلسطينيين هم من مجموعه خلينا نقول
ايه ايه مواطنين ايه اكثر هم همم عاقين
همم او او مواطن عاق وبالتالي نريد اعاده
تاديبه ليصرف ويعرف من هو صاحب البيت اللي
هي عمليه الشعار اللي رفعوا بين كبير خلال
همم
[موسيقى]
الانتخابات
هناك اشياء
منتظره يعني مثل
هيكتب عن الان على الاقل امكانيه سحب
الجنسيه همم امكانيه فصل المدرسين وجامعين
لانهم لديهم اراد ضد الاحتلال همم السماح
للشباب همم تفقد مواقع التواصل لعرب
الداخل ايضا فرض ضرائب كبيره على الجمعيات
التي تعمل في الوسط العربي هناك من بين
هذه ما اخطر ما يهدد
انه اخطر ما يهدد الفلسطينيين في الداخل
عمليه كل ما يتعلق مدخل مواجهه الجريمه
بمعنى انه تحويل مواجهه الجريمه لواحد
متعرف انه اليوم وحده من المشاكل الاساسيه
التي تواجه الفلسطينيين في الداله قضيه
الفلاتان والجريمه اللي هي بالمناسبه قضيه
سياسيه من الدرجه الاولى محاوله الدخول من
هذا المدخل من اجل بالفعل استخدام خلنا
نقول اعطاء صلاحيات واسعه للشباب من اجل
المراقبه الفلسطينيين في الداخل صاحب
هويات هو وامر وارد جدا عمليه همم همم سجن
قمع اكثر الفلسطيني هذه كلها امورده بشكل
كامل اليوم في الاجواء اللي موجوده شعور
بفقدان الامان الشخصي عند الانسان
الفلسطيني والمواطن شعور انه هو مهدد
بوجود وفي مكانه
لا ندري ما اذا كانت هذه الامور سيد
كردستان في نيويورك هذه الامور المتعلقه
بالفلسطينيين سواء في الضفه الغربيه
او في الداخل الاسرائيلي ما اذا كانت
مثاره قلقا بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه
بتقديرك
انا شخصيا
متعاطفا مع هذه الحكومه الجديده التي
الفها او شكلها
كانت محاوله يائسه لادخال بعض الوزراء
الذين كانوا يقولون اشياء تتنافى مع
الديمقراطيه وتتنافى مع القيم الامريكيه
التي اسستت عليها اسرائيل اذا اعتقد
والرغم ان هذا
الجهد حتى محاوله وضع قدم داخل
المسجد الاقصى كان
استفزازه ولم يبتسم بالحكمه وايضا تنافى
معه ما طلبته اداره بادن بالمحافظه على
الوضع الراهن من تغييره بحيث يبقى هناك
فرصه لتحقيق حل الدوالتين لكننا نسمع
من بعض هؤلاء الوزراء قناه كلاما يتنافى
مع هذا المنطق اعتقد ان همم
يتصور ان دونالد ترامب سيعود الى السلطه
والجمهور يونس يطلقه عنان له يفعل ما يشاء
هذا خطا ترامب يكون رئيس مره اخرى
والجمهوريون موقفهم ضعيف فقط شاهد السي ان
ان هذه الايام
لترى ماذا الانقسام داخل الصفوف فهم اذا
ما قيل وما تم فعله في الايام المبكره
لحكومه
الجديد لا لا تلقى عرضا في اوساط اداره
حقيقه بعض من كانوا تقليديا لاسرائيل
كانوا
اصدقاء لاسرائيل ليس لانها دوله يهوديه بل
لانها الدوله ديمقراطيه وصراحه كثير ما
يحدث الان يتنافى مع الديمقراطيه الدكتور
عازم كل ما سبق يجعل كثير من المراقبين
يتنبئون بامكانيه اندلاع انتفاضه ثالثه
لان الوضع لا يمكن ان يكون اسوا مما يمكن
ان يصل اليه الان هل هذا وارد يعني هناك
اكثر من سيناريو السيناريو الاول انه
الجانب الاسرائيلي نفسه هذه الحكومه نفسها
منقسمه على نفسها بشكل كبير جدا وهناك
انقسام في المجتمع الاسرائيلي ضخم هذا ما
يخيف الفلسطيني من هذا الناحيه انه
تاريخيا الاسرائيلين عندما كانت تحدث
الانقسامات داخليه كانوا يصدرون ازمتهم
الداخليه على شكل معركه او حرب في مكان
اخر وهذا يمكن ان يكون في الضفه الغربيه
يمكن يكون في قطاع غزه يمكن ان يكون في اي
مكان شن حرب وبالتالي هذا ممكن ان نجد
هجوم اسرائيلي يودره الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه
كفكره انتفاضه الفلسطينيه ربما الانتفاضه
على غرار انتفاض 87 قمر صعب جدا
لابعاد عزيزه جدا منها اعاده الانتشار
الاسرائيلي لطبيعه المستوطنات طبيعه
الحواجز هذه كلها امر يجعلها صعبه وحقيقه
وجود السلطه الفلسطينيه الان كل هذه صعب
ولكن انتفاضه لكن الشباب الفلسطيني
المجموعات المسلحه التي رايناها في جنين
في نابلس في بلاطه في الان في جنوب في
جنوب الضفه الغربيه ايضا هذه كلها يمكن ان
نجد انفسنا ان هؤلاء الشباب قد يجدوا
انفسهم في وضع انهم لابد ان ان يواجهوا
المستوطنين والجنود بشكل عسكري همم مباشر
لانه همم
بعدم وجود فعل دولي وعدم التزام اسرائيل
بالاتفاقيات هذا سي- وعدم قدره الاجهزه
الامنيه الفلسطينيه على التصدي للمستوطين
والجيش الاسرائيلي يعني اننا ربما نجد
سيناريو همم مواجهات عسكريه مستمره وهذا
ما اعتقد انه كان سيناريو قائم اكثر منهم
انتفاضه الثالثه ولكن طبعا سيكون هناك
حاضنه شعبيه تؤدي الى ما يشبه الانتفاضه
كان بشكل مختلف عن الماضي على كل دكتور
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده التي نتحدث
عنها برئاسه نتنياهو تضم 37 وزيرا بينهم
ثلاثه وزراء اثار كثيرا من الجدل
والانتقاد داخليا وخارجيا
تعتبر الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده برئاسه
نتنياهو الاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ الدوله
العبريه
فقدت اثمار بني كفير زعيمه حزب العظمه
اليهوديه وزيرا لوزاره الامن القومي وهو
من عتات المستوطنين واكثرهم من ثلاثا يعيش
في المستوطنه كريات اربعه المقامه على
اراضي الخليل ويعرف بعنصريته تجاه العرب
وانتمائه لحركات معاديه وجودهم في فلسطين
منذ ملاحقته كما ضمت مستوطنا اخر لا يقل
تطرفا وهو بيتسل ايلس مودريتش زعيم وحزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه وزيرا للماليه يعيش في
مستوطنه اكاديمي شماليه ضفه الغربيه ولا
يعترف بوجود شعب فلسطين
وعمل اسمه تريتش مديره لجمعيه يمنيه
متطرفات تلاحق الفلسطينيين وتعمل على هدم
بيوتهم بحجه البنائي غير المرخص وضمت هذه
الحكومه اريا درعي وزيرا للداخليه والصحه
من حزب شاس والذي يسكن في القدس المحتله
درعي حكم عليه بالسجن اربع سنوات
وبالغرامه بعد الكشف عن ملفات فساد
الاداري ورشا تلقاها خلال توليه مناصب
عامه حزب النقود احتفظ لنفسه بوزاره
الدفاع وشغلها يواف جلاند كما احتفظ
بوزاره الخارجيه
وشغلهاين ومن النقود ايضا رون دراما وزيرا
لشؤون الاستراتيجيه ويريد ليفين وزيرا
للقضاء وهو في المجلس الوزاري المصغر ايضا
ومن حزب يهدهد هتورال المتزميتين الغربيين
وزير الاسكان يستحق جولد كلوف
دكتوره هنيده غانم عندما نقول ان اسرائيل
ستصبح بهذا التشكيل الحكومي دوله دينيه
اصوليه متطرفه تنهي ما كانت تتغنى به
اسرائيل عاده من انها دوله علمانيه
ومتحضره بين قوسين
هل هذا صحيح
يعني هو صحيح جزئيه
من داخل اسرائيل بمنظور الاسرائيلي
اليهودي اللي موجود اللي بيحاول دائما
يعمل كانه في فصل ما بين ايش عم اسرائيل
عم تعمله وبتمارس تجاه الفلسطيني وايش
بتمارس نوع النظام الحكم اللي بتمارسوا
اتجاه اليهود بهذا المنطق اذا اخذنا انه
اسرائيل هي دوله ديمقراطيه يهوديه بمعنى
انه هي فعلا دوله ديمقراطيه من ناحيه
اليهود ولكن كمان نكر دائما يهوديه من
ناحيه فلسطينيه فهناك تغيير كبير اتي من
حيث تقليص اكثر مساحه الحريات الفرديه همم
بعض الحقوق اللي كانت
لمجموعات مثل المثليين وغير سيتم اكثر
محاضراتها همم عمليه ملاحقه مستمر لجمعيات
ولا شخصيات يساريه ووجود قوائم سوداء
بالمناسبه تم الاشاره لها مثلا همم موجوده
هناك همم اعلن او كشف عنها من قبل حزب نوع
من اللي هو ايضا سيكون بدور مهم جدا من
ناحيه همم
من ناحيه مناهج ايه التعليم والتربيه لانه
اخذ جزء من وزاره التربيه فالخاف الاساس
اللي موجود وعمليه على الحريات اللي هي
كان يضمنها همم تضمنها نوع النظام الموجود
اضافه الى ذلك الحديث اليوم هو عن عمليه
تغيير كبيره في منظومه القضاء الاسرائيليه
وعمليه تمرير قانون ما يسمى قانون التغلب
اللي اذا تمريره وهذا ما اعلن عنه يريد
وزير القضاء البارحه
بموجب وسيتمكن عمليا تتمكن الحكومه
باغلبيه ربما 61 شخص فقط 61 صوت من تمرير
اي قانون تريده حتى لو هذا القانون كان
يخالف مبادئ بقوانين اساس
لحد ما اتلم حوريات همم قانون اساس حريه
الانسان وكرامته وحتى لو قامت محكمه العدل
العليا بالغاء باعتباره يعني يناقد هذه
القوانين الاساس ستتمكن الحكومه من اعاده
سنو بمعنى عدم وجود اي تقييدك ايا كان على
هذه الحكومه من اجل انتم ممرر اي سياسه
تريدها واي قانون تريده صحيح هذا سيمس
بشكل كبير بحريات شخصيه وهمم لليهود في
داخل اسرائيل ولكن
المتضرر المركزي
والاساسيكون بالدرجه الاولى هم
الفلسطينيين خاصه في الضفه وفي قطاع غزه
وبعد ذلك ايضا الفلسطينيين في الداخل
كانت اسرائيل دائما سيد كردستان تتغنى
بانها دوله ديمقراطيه دوله قانون ومؤسسات
وهذا ما تشيد به دائما الولايات المتحده
هل يمكن ان تتغير الصوره لان ما نشهده
الان
فيما يتعلق بالقوانين والقضا ما اشرت اليه
الدكتوره هنيدي ومخاوف اخرى عديده سيقلص
كثيرا من هذا الطابعه الذي عرف عن اسرائيل
على الاقل
انه سيؤثر بشكل عميق في صوره اسرائيل داخل
اسرائيل اضافه الى صورتها داخل القطر
المتحده والانظمه الديمقراطيه الاخرى
الامر مقلق للغايه ما حدث تحدث عن حدث يوم
امس لم ينتشر بعض في الولايات المتحده وهو
لدرجه ان هذا
المقترح
بان تكون هناك اغلبيه بسيطه في الكناسه
بامكانها قلب قرار المحكمه الدستوريه هذا
يعني ان الاغلبيه في الكنيسه تستطيع ان
تفعل اي شيء مهما كان مريعا والمحكمه
العليا لم تستطيع ايقاف ذلك هذا امر لن
يمر بكرم والله الذي تقبل
سخاء
وايضا عندما يحاول نتنياهو ان يناشد
اليهود من كل انحاء العالم ان يهاجروا الى
اسرائيل هذه يعني في نظرهم انه لا ينشر
مجتمعنا وطنا اسرائيليا يرحب باليهود ولا
ولا يجعل من اسرائيل مكانا
يشعرون فيه بالترحاب مثل هذا المقترح اذا
ما تمره وهو ان في اغلبيه بسيطه في
الكنيسه يمكنه او يمكن ان يمكنه ان تفعل
اي شيء بغض النظر عن كونه عادلا ام لا هذا
سيكون له مقالات كبيره في صفوف اليهود
وغير اليهود
ويعتقد ان اداره بادن حسب تقديري ستتحدث
بصوت مرتفع عن هذا القضيه لانه امر يتنافى
مع القيم الامريكيه وايضا قيم اسرائيل
التي كنا نعرفها تاريخيا اعتقد ان هذا خطا
حسابات كبير من جانبه اذا ما تصور بان هذا
الامر سيمر بصراحه سيظر بجهوده لتطبيعه
العلاقات مع البلدان العربيه الاخرى كل ما
قلنا تصرف
او زاد التطرف حكومته ستقل فرسه في
التطبيع وربما ستكون كاسات سلبيه حتى مع
البلدان التي تم التطبيعه معها حتى الان
يعني سنعود اكثر لموضوع ال همم لاحقا ولكن
همم دكتور حازم هناك قوانين مخيفه وصفت
بالمخيفه تنتظر الاسرائيليين يعني مثلا
هناك شركات سيسمح لها برفض تقديم خدماتهم
يوم السبت
للمتدينين هناك حديث عن فصل بين البنات
والبنين في المدارس هناك فضاءات عامه ربما
يمنع النساء من الذهاب اليها وفقا رؤيا
الدينيه المتطرفه لهؤلاء هذا ما جعل
الفنان ستقول هذه الحكومه ستكون كارثه على
الليبراليين الاسرائيليين وكذلك على
الفلسطينيين ماذا تتوقع من مثل هذه
القوانين يعني اسمه حتى يقول انه يريد
تطبيق الشريعه اليهوديه في وزاره الماليه
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن يعني
حتى فكره الاقتصاد الليبرالي الاسرائيلي
اللي كان يتم التغني في ايضا يبدو انه
مهدد رغم انه هذا كلام يتناقض ايضا مع
نتنياهو دعني اقول ما يحدث ولا يقلق فقط
الاسرائيليين داخل اسرائيل يعني ال- ال-
الامس كان الحامات الامريكيين يحتاجون حول
ما يحدث في ال- في الحكامه الامريكيه
يحتاجون حول اسرائيل او وقعوا عريضه همم
انت حتى في فتره حكم نتنياهو السابقه سنه
2017 بعض رجال الاعمال الامريكان
الامريكيين والكنديين من اليهود طبعا
بداوا بسحب استثماراتهم من داخل اسرائيل
حتى في الحكومه 2017 20 فما بالك الان انا
باعتقادي انا
سنشهده سنشهد نوع من يعني اذا استمرت
الامور وهي يبدو انها تستمر سيكون هناك
زلزال اجتماعي سياسي بين الاسرائيليين
لانه ايضا لديك مجموعه يعني همم في احد
الاحزاب القديمه في هذه من حلفانا نتنياهو
اليهوديه الموحد التوراه يهوديه الموحده
همم هي تقول انه حتى اليهود الاصلاحين في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وزير الصحه
السابق في حكومه كان يقول هذا دين ولكنه
ليس دين يهودي فليه فبالنسبه الى هناك
تكثير يعني اتجاه تكفيره كبير داخل هذه
الحكومه لحتى يهود اصوليين اخرين ليهود
اصلاحين ما يسمى اليهود الاصلاحيين هناك
جدل كبير حول المسجد الاقصى ليس فقط فيما
يتعلق في المسلمين ايضا حتى منع جزء لا
يستهان فيه من النساء ومن اليهود
الولايات الامريكيين من الصلاه عند المسجد
عند الحائط الحائط الغربي للمسجد الاقصى
ولكن توجد معارضه اسال عنها الدكتور هنيدي
معرضه همم فئات اسرائيليه معينه لهذا لهذا
التوجه يعني ما مستقبل هو يعني مثلا يعير
جولان وعضو كنيسه سابق ونائب رئيس اركان
دعا قاده ال- ال- الجيش الجنرالات الى رفض
الخدمه اصلا اذا كان سيعين وزيران في ال-
في الحكومه يعني
78 قاضي همم متقاعد امضاء عريضه تحذر من
مخاطر المس بجهاز القضاء والديمقراطيه
الاسرائيليه
هذا هذا المد المعارض ما مستقبله
استوى
السياسه السياسيين بدرجات مختلفه ولكن
هناك ايضا مستوى المهني بمعنى من الجيش
تحذيرات مختلفه وهناك ايضا احد الاحتجاجات
المهمه للاجب الانتظار يعني النظر اليها
بجديه هي همم
المستثمرين من مجال الهايتك حوالي عدد
مئات من الشخصيات وجهه مكتوب انه السياسه
الاسرائيليه كما تتضح معالمها حاليا قد
تضر بالاستثمارات في مجال الهايتك وقد تضر
عمليا مضره التاج همم ما يشجل دره التاج
للاقتصاد الاسرائيلي دائما يفتخر في
نتانيا اهو هذا لمستوى معين على مستوى
شعبي نرى هناك بدايات خلينا نقول انت مال
ومن محاولات لتنظم وجبه تعبير ها الاول في
المظاهرات اللي تمت خارج مبنى الكناست يوم
همم يوم
المصادقه على الخطوط العريضه همم للحكومه
ولكن انا بيهمني اخي محمد انه اوضح نقطه
انه طالما كان النقاش هو حول القضايا
المرتبطه بحقوق اليهود في داخل هاي الدوله
وكانه عم بيصير في مصر بالليبراليه وقيم
الليبراليه ستظل هذه يعني لن يكون بالفعل
تغيير حقيقي مرتبط لانه القضيه الاساسيه
والمركزي اللي موجوده اللي هي دي الذي
يصنع خط الانتاج عمليا اللي راح ياخذ خط
الانتاج للعنصريه وخط الانتاج للتطرف هو
وجود الاحتلال هذا هو دي ان ايه المشكله
الاساسي وطالما دائما سيتم التركيز على ما
يحدث من ناحيه القيم الليبراليه وتضييق
الهامش اللي بيرالي وانا يعني باعتقد انه
يمكن حاله الغض الاستياء والخوف اللي
اصابت اجزاء كبيره من المجتمع اللي بيرالي
العلماني انه التطبيق عليهن هذه الدائره
هو في هيك نوع من من الخوف انه يصيروا
فلسطينيه ههه بشكل او باي عين نحن كمان
شوي بنصير فلسطينيه
المشكله الاساسيه هي عمليه الفوقيه
اليهوديه وعمليه اداره مناطق من هذا
المنطلق وبالتالي اذا لم يتم التعامل يعني
ترتيب او تنظيم الاحتجاجات على اساس
معارضه هذه المشكله الاساسيه رح نرجع على
نفس الشيء
نعم ال ال ايضا التساؤل الكبير الان ااا
سيد قدستاين هو كيفيه التعامل المجتمع
الدولي مع هذه الحكومه واساسا الولايات
المتحده ربما في مقال الاخير للوشنتون
بوست مقال كتبه وهو مفاوض امريكي سابق
وكذلك دانييل كارتر
داعيه حكومه بايدن الى الرد بقوه على هذه
الحكومه وطالب حتى بعدم عقد اجتماعات مع
هؤلاء الوزراء المتطرفين
سواءتش او همم
هل يمكن ان تستجيب حكومه بايدو لنداءات من
هذا القبيل
الاخبار صار انه لا يوجد احد يفهمه
المجتمع الدولي بصراحه
الشرق الاوسط في الحكومه الامريكيه افضل
من جوبا ايضا لانه لم يكن في الحياه
العامه ممارسه المنظر العام 1972 كان ايضا
رئيسا
للجنه الشؤون الخارجيه المنبثقه عن مجلس
الشيوخ وكان نائبا للرئيس 18 عام في رئاسه
باراك اوباما ومن عده جوانب كان يمسكه
بالملفات الدوليه في اداره اوباما لانه
اوباما ادرك انه كان يعرف العالم بذلك
الشكل الطيب
لهذه الاسباب اقول ان
كل هذا الخطوات
زراعه وما يقولونه سيكون حقيقه
مسيئا بشكل عميق اللي بايدون والا انا لا
اقول ان بعض سيتصرف بناء على نصيحه تعرض
من غيره لكن هو عليه ان يقول نحن لا نريد
ان نتعامل معكم بنفس الشاكره اذا كان هناك
اشخاص عنصريين مثلكم في الولايات المتحده
ايضا لن يود التعامل معهم اذا كان هناك
اعضاء في مجلس النواب والشيوخ اذا كانوا
يقومون بسياساتها ويطلقون تصريحات عنصريه
باذن الله لن يتعامل معهم هذا ينطبق على
الوزراء في اسرائيل الى ايضا مره اخرى
اقول ان الناس
اعترفوا خطا حسابات عميق وكبير جدا
وهذا من النوع الخطا الذي ربما لن تتقبله
الحكومه الامريكيه ولا الشعب الامريكي ولا
الراي العام
وربما نحتاج الى بعض الوقت لكي نستوعب
حجمه وعمق ما يقوم به
حكومته لكن اعتقد ان المجتمع الدولي اللي
بيقربته لن يتقبل ذلك فقط ربما الحكام
الاستبداديون في العالم فقط هم الذين
يرتاحون
لافعالنا الثانيه وهذا لن يكون كافيا
لادامه اسرائيل عسكريا
واقتصاديه
وبالتاكيد فيما تتعلق بقطاعات العمل التي
يحتاجها الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي وخاصه في
مجال التقنيه العاليه التقوى وغيرها التي
يحتاجها الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي لا اعتقد ان
اسرائيل ستكون بيئه جاذبه للاستثمارات اذا
كنت مستثمرا تريد ان تستثمر مالك تحتاج
الى استثباب لحكم القانون والا لن تدري من
سيتملك استثماراتك التي
تستثمرها الان لا نرى استثمارا لحكم
القانون سوا مبدا حصول على الاغلبيه في
الكونغ في الكنيسه هذا لا يكفي للمستثمار
ان المطلوب ربما من حلفاء اسرائيل
الغربيين الضغط على هذه الحكومه كما كما
يقال ربما ردود الفعل بعد اقتحام بني كثير
للمسجد الاقصى الموقف الامريكي البريطاني
الفرنسي الالماني هل يمكن التعويل على هذه
المواقف يعني ننزل تايمز مثلا قالت على
على حلفاء اسرائيل الغربيين الا يقفوا
مكتوفي الايدي لابد ان يتدخل من الان قبل
ان تزيد الامور استفهالا هل هذا ممكن يعني
حتى نجيب هذا السؤال يجب ان يعني نستعرض
كيف يفكر نتنياهو
و حلفاؤه في الحكومه همم عندما تحدث عن
شخص مسائل الانتمار بن جيفير هو لديه ست
مقاعد فقط من اصل 120 5% من مقاعد الكنيست
ولكن هو اسمه تريتش يتحدثون وكانهم حتى
المحكمه العليا في اسرائيل يجب الغائها
لصالح الانتخابات علمنا انه هم يعني قوتهم
الشعبيه حتى داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
محدوله نتنياه لديه من الغرور حتى يعتقد
بانه لديه حلفاء في الولايات المتحده داخل
حزب الجمهوري وحتى داخل حزب الديمقراطي
بحيث انه يستطيع ان يهزم كما هزم برايه
اوباما سابقا نتذكر الصدام الذي كان موجود
في فتره اوباما يعني ايضا داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه همم هناك همم يعني
الامر ليس ابيض واسود هناك الكثير من
الكواليس ايضا مهم جدا لتنياهو يعتقد بانه
لديه حلفاء بالصين مع الصين مع الهند الان
روسيا وبانه وبالتالي هو ان الولايات
المتحده رغم كل الدعم ال- ال- ال- العسكري
والاقتصادي الامريكي لكن نتنياهو لديه من
الغرور انه يستطيع حتى ان يوجد لديه حلفاء
عرب بعد التطبيع وهؤلاء الذين يسهلون
مشاريع مع الهند ومع الصين بحيث انه يريد
ان يقول للعالم ان الثقه الثقل الذي اهتم
فيه ليس فقط الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهمم وايضا لا ننسى انه نتنياهو بالنسبه
له موضوع البقاء هذه الحكومه والتغيير في
المحك- في القوانين هو قضيه بقاء همم
وبالتالي هو سيطلق يد بنجفير بالدرجه
الاولى ضد الفلسطينيين ليقتل يدخل الاقصى
ليخرج كما يريد حتى يسن قوانين دينيه كما
يريد وبالمقابل هو سيتولى الشان الخارجي
وعلى اساس انه قادر ان يطبع مع العرب في
نفس الوقت قادر ان اا يجد حلفاء في اسيا
وغير روسيا بدون ان يحتاج الى ان يقوم باي
شيء مع الفلسطينيين بانه بامكاني ان اضرب
فلسطينيين وابقى عالميا موجود على ذكر
التطبيق دكتور هنيده غانم هل تعتقدين بان
رغم كل هذا القبح في ااا شكل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه وتوجهاتها سيستمر
التطبيع في الذهنيه الاسرائيليه هذا الامر
الوارد سيستمر مع المغرب مع الامارات مع
السعوديه كما يطمحون
ولكن اذا قرانا كمان مره
الاتفاقيات نجد انه التركيز هناك على
الدفع قدما باتجاه مزيد من التطبيع مع
الدول العربيه عمليا والحديث يتم كثيرا في
الفتره الاخيره
دول جديده للتطبيع ما هو الحديث طبعا بشكل
خاص عن السعوديه
سيرجع يعود الى نفس النقطه التي انها في
عام 2021 بعد
اتفاقيه ابرهم هو يريد ان يعود الى هذه
النقطه وكانه يستمر همم منه هناك هذا نقطه
ايضا توافق موجوده داخل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
همم هل سينجح هذا همم لا اعرف يتعلق كثيرا
ضد الفعل في الجانب في الجانب الديوان
العربيه ولكن هذا بالضبط ما يراهن علينا
ثاني هذا بالضبط ما يراهن علينا ثاني وانا
بعتقد انه عمليه حتى دخول بين كبير اقتحام
الاقصى امبارح كان نوع من يعني زي زي تينج
يعني محاوله جسم نبض كيف ستكون ردود الفعل
انا بعتقد نقطه مهمه كمان انه نحن نتحدث
عن انه كانه في حكومه مجانين موجوده في
مطريتي وبنت كبير ولكن هذه الحكومه هي
اللي اختارها مره ثانيه ياهو هي حكومي
اللي هي تذهب باتجاه رؤيه نتنياهو ومشروع
نتنياهو اللي حكي عنه بالالفين 2020 من
حيث الضم ومن حيث يعني عمليه تبييض
الاستيطان ومشروع بالاساس وهم يعني ما في
اختلاف بيناتهم
في النهايه كيف سيكون التعامل العربي هناك
من اعتبر زياره من كثير ربما ضربت ضربه
قاسيه اي طموح لهذه الحكومه في تطبيع
العلاقه مع السعوديه مثلا ولكن ماذا عن
الاردن ماذا عن الامارات التي يقال انه
سيزورها نتنياه معنا يفترض ان هذه الحكومه
يفترض انها ستنهي اي تطبيق مقبل مع همم
الدول العربيه يعني موضوع التطبيع همم من
شقير الدول التي طبعت الفعل للاسف اصبحت
دخلت في مشاريع اقتصاديه وماليه يبدو
التراجع فيها الان اذا صعب دخول جيده
للتطبيع قد لا يحدث ليس بسبب ان هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه فقط سيئه جدا ولكن
لانه حتى طبيعه تركيب الامريكيه مختلفه
فمثلا على سبيل المثال لم يعد همم الفريق
ترامب الذي كان موجود هو نفسه الذي كان
لديه اولويه التطبيعه فبالتالي الدول ربي
الان ليس سوار التطبيع لاسباب مختلفه ليست
فقط هذه الحكومه للاسف اسرائيل لديها مبدا
تسير عليه
ستصبح في حرج اكبر من السابق لان التطبيق
مع هذه الحكومه سيكون اسوا بكثير لدى رايه
العام على الاقل مما سبق مئه بالمئه ولكن
حكومه ثنتين ياهو لم تكن افضل كثيرا يعني
حكومات عندما تم توقيع اتفاقيات السلام
معها اتفاقيه كاننا ثاني ياهو ترامب لديهم
خطه لتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه وكانت كل كل
شيء موجود لكن انا اعتقد ايضا هناك امر
مهم جدا اسرائيل لديها قاعده داعي عالم
يقول ما يشاء ونحن نفعل ما يشاء ما دامت
ردود الفعل ما زالت في اطار البيانات ومن
في اطار الشاشه والادانه لن يحدث شيء طول
دون ان يتغير دون ان يتغير ال- ال- الوضع
الاقتصادي هنا يكون هناك ضغط امريكي
واوروبي حقيقي
على اسرائيل ماديا فهذا امر صعب الدول
العربيه اذا اردت ان تتحدث يجب ان تفتح
ملفات مع الدول كثيره في العالم اسرائيل
تدخل معها معها الان في تحالفات جديده
وخريطه تحالفات اسرائيل نفسها تختلف
عالميا واقلاميا شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور احمد
جميل لازم على حضورك معنا هنا في الاستديو
شكرا ايضا للدكتوره هنيده غانم من القدس
شكرا ايضا ل ريتشارد ااه من نيويورك
هذه الحلقه نبدا بهذه التغريده لوزير
الخارجيه الاردني ايمن الصفدي يقول فيها
اقتحام وزيرا اسرائيل
خطير ندينه ونحذر مره اخرى من عواقب جميع
التدابير الاسرائيليه غير القانونيه التي
تقود افاق السلام ولا يمكن ان تتسبب سوى
في المزيد من الصراع والانث يجب احترام
الوضع الراهن في الاماكن المقدسه في
تغريده للخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
الدكتور صالح النعامي يقول
يشغل المتدينون في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده 15 حقيبه وزاريه من اصل 29 حقيبه
حصل الحكمات على ثمانيه وزارات اهمها
الداخليه الاسكان الصحه وضمن حقائب
المتدينين المهمه هناك الماليه الاستيطان
الامن الوطني
لو حدث هذا عندنا لكان التهم الاسلم وتدين
الفضاء العام جاهزته الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ياسر الزعاره يقول في اليوم الذي
دنس شريفه في الاعتلال بن كثير المسجد
الاقصى تحدث نتنياه في اول جلسه لحكمته
متجاهلا الحدث ومؤكدا عزمه على تعليق
الاتفاقيات القائمه مع السد دول العربيه
وتحقيق الدراسات مع دول اخرى بؤس الوضع
العربيه الرسمي بجانب اعز قياده رام الله
هو الذي يشجعه على الغطرسه
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت
الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي قال في تغريده
عوده بنيامين نتنياهو اطول رئيس وزراء
خدمه في منصب رئيس الوزراء بمصادقه
الكنيست على راسي حكومته السادسه بتحالف
حزبه اللكود مع الاحزاب الصغيره الدينيه
الاكثر تطرفا وعنصريه من عوتات اليمين
الصهيوني الفاسي هي بمثابه اعلان حرب يسقط
جميع الاقنعه وننهي بهذه التغريده للكاتب
والصحفي الامريكي
حيث غرد يقول عندما يقول المعلقون ان
حكومه نتنياهو الجديده ستؤدي الى تاكل
الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه فهم في افضل
الاحوال نصفين نعم يمكن ان يؤدي الى تاكل
بعض الحقوق لليهود لكن بالنسبه لمعظم
الفلسطينيين لم تكون اسرائيل ديمقراطيه
اصلا
بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه موعدنا
يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل باذن الله مع
سيناريوهات جديده في امان الله
[موسيقى]